تحت عنوان حريه التعبير هي الاساس والممهد
لكافه اشكال حقوق الانسان احتفت منظمه
اليونسكو باليوم العالمي لحريه الصحافه في
مقر الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
الاوضاع في مجتمعاتنا وحين تتراجع فان كل
الحقوق تتراجع معها
وبكلمات قويه حذر الامين العام للامم
المتحده من الهجمات على حريه الصحافه في
شتى انحاء العالم في ظل مساء لاضعاف
الحقيقه والثقه بالاعلام في مواجهه
المعلومات المغلوطه ونظريات المؤامره
منذ بدء الاحتفاء باليوم العالمي لحريه
الصحافه كان لدى اثنتي عشره دوله فقط
قوانين لحريه الاعلام في حين ان
135 دوله اليوم لديها مثل هذه القوانين
رغم ذلك فالصوره تبدو اكثر قتامه بارتفاع
عدد الصحفيين الذين قتلوا عام 2022
بنسبه 50% عن العام الذي سبقه ليصل عددهم
الى 67
الصوره اكثر قتامه بالنسبه للصحفيين العام
الماضي تم اعتقاله
363 صحفيا وهذا الرقم الاعلى منذ 30 عاما
وكنا نوثق ذلك وتم قتل 67 صحفيا بمن فيهم
صحفيه الجزيره شيرين ابو عاقله وهذا بسبب
تراجع الديمقراطيه في العالم ما نحتاجه هو
بلدان تدعم حريه الصحافه ليس بالكلمات بل
بالافعال
ومع اقتراب الذكرى الاولى لاغتيال شيرين
ابو عاقله تواصلت المطالب بتحقيق العداله
في قضيتها في حين سيعرض وثائقي انتجته
الجزيره على هامش فعاليات اليوم العالمي
لحريه الصحافه كما تم التفكير بمواصله
اعتقال كل من ربيع محمد عبد الواحد وبهاء
الدين ابراهيم نعمه الله صحفيي الجزيره في
مصر في حين يحتجز مراسل صحيفه
واوير مارك
نحن هنا للاحتفال باليوم العالمي لحريه
الصحافه وقد نظمت اليونسكو هذا المؤتمر
المهم لكن المؤتمرات لا توفر حلا للمشكله
واعتقد ان هناك حاجه لاتخاذ اجراءات قويه
على الارض للضغط على اسرائيل والتاكد من
تحقيق العداله واذا لم يكن من الممكن
القيام بذلك على المستوى الوطني فيجب ان
يكون دوليا
30 عاما مرت على تخصيص يوم عالمي لحريه
الصحافه لكن التحديات التي تواجه الصحفيين
تتنامى لتصدر دعوات من هنا لحمايه
الصحفيين و لوقف ملاحقتهم وسجنهم في ظل
مساء لتقويض الثقه بالمهنه وبالحقيقه بسبب
كويك الجزيره من مقر الامم المتحده في
نيويورك